-First of all, happy new year.
-And to you.
-You have a daughter now.
Did you enjoy the holidays
with her?
-I did, yeah. I mean, yeah.
-Good.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Do you think she would say
the same thing?
-She might have
a different story.
-But I was wondering
if being a parent --
because I felt this
a fair amount.
You become more empathetic.
You become a little kinder
when you have a child.
Don't take this the wrong way.
You've always been cruel
to my dog Frisbee.
-Right.
[ Laughter ]
-Do you feel any different about
her now that you're a parent?
-No.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-But I will also say
you now have kids.
-Yeah.
-And I'm like, why keep Frisbee?
[ Laughter ]
But I will say this.
-Yeah.
-You sent your holiday card
to me.
-Yep.
-And you did actually take into
account my Frisbee hatred.
And I really appreciate it.
-Yeah, I should give credit
to my wife here.
She wrote -- she hand-wrote
on the back of the envelope,
"Caution --
Frisbee photo contained."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
And I picked it up and looked at
my wife and I was like, "Uh-oh.
I don't know
if I want to look at this."
And then, sure enough, I opened
it up and what do I see?
-There you go. Come on!
-Frisbee with the Star of David?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Haven't we been through enough,
Seth?
[ Laughter and applause ]
Frickin' little skeleton rat!
-She is not a skeleton rat.
-Oh, man!
-Look at her. She's gorgeous.
-The kids are beautiful.
Again, I'm a human lover.
And I like almost every dog.
-Was it this year or last year
where you sent it back to us
with Frisbee out of the photo?
[ Laughter ]
Because you did that.
-I have so much
less spare time now.
[ Laughter ]
I have to come here
to talk about it.
-Hey, congratulations
on the Golden Globes.
-Thank you.
-You did a fantastic job.
[ Cheers and applause ]
There's a couple of things
we've both hosted.
This is one of them.
-Yeah.
-It is a -- People say this
all of the time.
It is a tough room.
Not because people don't have
a good sense of humor.
It is one of the loudest rooms
you could ever play.
-Deafeningly loud.
-Yeah.
-People are not paying attention
to what you're doing on stage.
They're just kind of talking
to each other and being famous.
-Yeah. Well, that's the thing.
You want to tell everybody to
shut up, but then you look,
and they're all so much
more famous than you.
-Yes, exactly.
You can't be like, "Hey,
Nicholson! I'm doing my joke!"
[ Laughter ]
He'll say, "Yeah, I'll eat you."
-We had a -- You had a --
Obviously, the same way I did --
a lot of friends
pitched in jokes.
-Yes.
-And some writers
from this show, actually,
went out and were backstage
with you.
-Absolutely, I did.
I worked with three of your
writers, Amber, Jenny and Ally.
-Yeah, and there they are,
right over there.
-Hey, Andy!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hey.
Hey, Andy.
Rhinoceros teeth, remember?
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, I love it!
-Sorry. What's that?
-Oh, no, it's just a thing
that we do now
since we worked together
on the Globes.
-Oh, it was, like,
an inside joke then.
Did you guys have fun?
-Oh, so much fun.
-Oh, it was great.
-Yeah, I mean, it was different,
you know?
-What do you mean?
Like, different than this?
-No, just -- better.
-Andy just gets it.
-You know what we mean, Steve.
-Seth.
-Oh, my God! Seth! Oh.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, Seth.
-I mean, you know.
It was the Globes,
and it's a big deal.
You wouldn't understand.
-No, yeah, I hosted it
last year.
[ Laughter ]
-I thought she did.
-Yeah, you were great!
-Thank you!
-Yeah.
-Anyway, Andy, we'll see you
at the after party.
-Wait, this show
has an after party?
-Oh, Seth, you wouldn't like it.
It's just a bunch of people
you know and work with.
Shh!
-Yeah, I, uh, I think
it's cancelled.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's cancelled.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-I'll see you
at the "cancelled" after party.
-All right. Give it up for
these awful, awful women!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Just kidding. Love you guys!
Bye, my three new best friends!